البكر يا ايه
من التدريب المستمر هذه اولى الدفاعاتي في
المعسكرات الموحده بولايه عليل
من قوات المتحاربه في ما بينها الى قوات
موحده تجمعها شعارات عسكريه بعد ان كانت
تفرقها بلمس
كزمله في كل جميع الوحدات
في الدوله
[موسيقى]
هذه القوات المتخرجه من الوحدات النظاميه
المختلفه تشكل نواه جيشي دوله جنوب
السودان بعد تنفيذ اتفاق السلام الذي قضى
بدمج قوات الحكومه والمعارضه في قوات
موحده لكن تم تحديات عديده ما زالت تواجه
البند الخاص بتنفيذ الترتيبات الامنيه
خاصه ترتيبات اللوجسيه وتمويل القوات
النصر اتفاق والترتيبات الامنيه على ادماج
القوات بنسب مختلفه واعادتها هيكله
القياده العليا للاجهزه الامنيه
ومرهطفات وخلافات العميقه بين الرئيس سلف
اكير والاعبي ريال مشاعر كاد التنف
الاتفاق قبل ان يتدخل السودان ويطوي قوه
الخلافات بين الجانبين ليعبوره الى هذه
المرحله من تخرج القوه ويرى محللون ان
الاصلاحات في المؤسسه العسكريه البلاد قد
تستغرق وقتا طويلا بسبب تعقيدات التمثيل
العراقي في المؤسسه العسكريه اصلاح
المنظومه الامنيه نبدا كيف انه يعني يكون
في الجيش غومي صعب مهني معروف
وجيش
يدربوها العقيده قتاليه معروف وجيش همم
وجيش احترمت الدستور بتاع الدوله ويعمل
بها في خطامي محاولاتي اعاده المياه الى
مجاريها في المؤسسه العسكريه بجنوب
السودان تتطلع الدوله الحديثه من خلال
القوات الموحده الى توفير الامن خصوصا في
المناطق الملتهبه التي تمثل بؤره صراع لا
سيما اقليم اعلاني وترغب الحكومه في نزع
السلاح من عيد المواطنين وانهاء النائب
المسلح لقطعان المشيئه ووقف الهجمات
الانتخابيه بين القبائل والاثناءات ما
في شباب في مناطق عالميه الكبرى يبدا من
ملكاته نقولهم ايه الحكومه في ظل التحديات
الامنيه التي تواجهها دوله جنوب السودان
في الوقت الرحم قد تشهد البلاد في الايام
المقبله بعض الاستقرار النسبي بانتشار تلك
القوات في مناطق التوتر لكن سيظل التعاطي
مع المجموعات المسلحه التي صمت اذانها عن
الدعوات المتكرره للانضمام اكبر اختبار
تواجهه جنوب السودان حيث الجزيره من ولايه
النيل جنوب السودان